Now, let's go ahead and
declare some variables for
each of the primitive
types that we saw earlier.
So now we have a couple more variables
and I've explicitly stated the type for
each, even though it's really
not necessary, except for
the case of the Float and the Double.
The Character would be the same as well,
so it'll leave that one.
I'm want to remove all the other
ones really quick, but
the rest of them I think Swift font file
are just fine and we can double check.
So that's an outline we wanted.
That's the string and that's a boolean.
Now what about these float and
double types?
They seem to represent pretty similar
values their floating point numbers.
But why would you use
one over the other?
Well that comes down to
an issue of precision and
being able to most accurately
represent a floating point number.
Truth be told computers actually have
a pretty difficult time doing this.
Usually computers even have special
hardware dedicated just two
floating point numbers.
Typically you want to use double instead
of float because it can handle floating
point numbers at a higher precision,
but double isn't always better.
In cases where speed may be more
important than the accuracy of
a floating point number,
you may want to choose Float instead.
Next let's try changing
a variable's value.
Let's change my jersey number.
Since we've already
cleared my jersey number,
we can just change it with
the simple syntax here.
We have the name of the variable.
An equal sign and
then the new value that we want.
So following this change,
we can see that my jersey number went
from being 5 here to being 80 here.
And we can keep doing this
as many times as we like.
However when we change a variable's
value we must ensure that the new value
is of the right type.
So in this case every single
one of these are integers so
the compiler wouldn't complain.
But let's try something
a little bit different.
In this case we're going to try
to change my jersey number to
something that would typically
be inferred as a string.
And this is a problem.
We can see that the compiler's
complaining, and
it says we cannot assign a value of
type string to value of type n because
my jersey number was declared as
an injured it expects an integer.
And the reason this is a problem is
because Swift is strongly typed or
we might say that Swift is
a strongly typed language.
This means that once a variables
type has been declared or
set it cannot change.
So if you look at where my jersey
number is declared we know that it's
an integer, and it can't change.
Therefore it can't be
set to the string here.